the Joe Rogan experience hey well this
guy's you know buy so go easy on him or
whatever this New York this isn't your
New York your experience in this yeah
all new you are I'm a New York guy right
but you don't get that out here oh yeah
you live like that I did a show at the
store and I was like there's a lot of
guys on the show we're gonna eat in
trouble and Santino was like shut up
this is LA I was like Jesus la is a full
on meritocracy there's a lot of funny
women but they have to actually be funny
why is that you don't get on a show just
cuz you're a Czech but it's weird that
that's even controversial like this
ribbon is funny minorities blah blah
blah everybody why it's it's more
offensive to put you on because you have
a gash well that's not like I was saying
about this girl that was telling me that
she wants to have a certain look for her
writers room I'm like that's weird the
look should be hilarious yes it would
find the funniest [ __ ] people that
are willing to work for you right don't
worry about I want black gay women I
want this I want that listen I don't do
it yeah it's a trap cuz you're not gonna
get the best show that way of course the
best show is fun the best comments if
they happen to be all women yeah I get
diversity you want to pretty like I
don't know all the [ __ ] black people
know or Asian people know so get them in
here but like just get the funny ones
yeah no problem is actual racism yeah
it's not and guilt
yeah else is a problem that's definitely
problem with some folks yeah but but the
actual racism is the real problem not
like ensuring that this diversity to the
point where you're seeking it out yeah
lemon a ting the better candidates that
just happen to be a white woman or a
white man yeah you know you want this
instead very strange but it's not wise
okay because your product is gonna
suffer because if you're if someone's
got a skill like the the real problem is
someone I mean and it rarely happens
I would imagine where someone decides
that the far better person like it
depends on the job for sure but if if
you're in a city like sports it's one of
the reasons why Sports is so awesome
yeah like in the Jack Johnson days they
did try to do that they did try to keep
Jack Johnson from fighting for the top
court husband for a system totally
didn't want to
black man - right because they knew he
was the best of course they were trying
to keep him from being the best but in
most areas of life I feel like if you're
really good you get ahead and yeah if
you don't that's the problem the problem
is racism the promise someone trying to
stop you from getting ahead just because
you are whatever you want or sexism or Y
or sexist yeah yes that's the real
problem the response to that is not
force diversity there yes that is like
racism is awful it should all great but
it's not that you should force diverse I
agree I think it's strange you make a
mistake yeah you're making a mistake
yeah and it's weird and kind of wrong
and kind of comedy yeah of course but
it's just and I get the whole we gotta
like we went so far the wrong way then
now we're trying to we go far too far
the other way well like it's weird that
they people can't see that and then they
call you racist and you're like you
don't even have it's always people
without black friends who call you
racist ironically you know you don't
even know any black people and why are
you using that word so liberally yeah
weird word to say that but you know what
I'm like why are you using that word so
that's an important word and you can't
just like in a world where we can't fat
shame and [ __ ] shame you can call racism
and sexism so quick races are the worst
thing in America be a bigot is the worst
thing may be pedophilia but like that's
weird that you use that so quick you
don't even know the person well it's
crazy it's an easy weapon to use in
dragons and you've got a battle axe to
throw yeah let it fly I agree with this
ain't D&D baby this is this is life and
people's people's careers will get
ruined because you want to win an
argument yeah ah it makes me sick and I
hate yeah now I'm going on but I hate
these new it's all whitey by the way I
hate these people who get like real
evolved all of a sudden and then they
gotta tell us about their involvement
it's like yeah we knew that [ __ ] already
but we're not going on on social media
and having like a big parade about how
evolved you are
we already knew these people are
marginalized in that but just cuz you
found out now we got to hear your side
that's privileged yeah that's the
ultimate privilege like like these
documentaries about I have privilege you
can pay two million bucks to do the
documentary a [ __ ] what are you crazy
it's insane like you think blackberry
joining this they're going oh this is
[ __ ] embarrassing and whoa what how
come I don't get a show you have the
privilege again still it's so entitled
and narcissistic they can't even see
outside their own gun god sorry
Thank You mark Normand yeah well that'll
get me camps I'm gonna bang the gavel
mr. speaker you have four minutes to
respond I want good I want it all we're
gonna I want everybody good job and I'm
all about the fun but you also don't
want anybody suffer sexism and don't
want lawyers of course but you want the
best people to be chosen yeah I do too
and I think those things aren't mutually
exclusive I think it's possible I
pitched the show about having these
stand-ups and do this and P were like we
love it here's a list of people we think
you should eat put on and I read the
list I was like these are all hack
retards this sucks
these people are all unfunny and I know
all of them you start going why why
would they want to use these people
they're talentless I've watched them I
do shows with them the industry sucks
the industry is a bunch of finance [ __ ]
they're all just wearing a suit no you
know whatever but they're all wearing a
suit and then they were in the room and
they don't know anything about comedy I
know about comedy I'm in though I'm in
the trenches I'm in the clubs they don't
know any about comedy but they're all in
a suit in a in a you know warehouse or a
nice building downtown and they go this
is what we should do so they look good
they look whoa core progressive but it's
not funny like I hate that and they all
go I love Pryor I love that guy I love
Karlin now you don't name me one bit
you don't know anything about comedy
you're just you does at work you got a
coffee machine over here and you got a
nice car and you want to keep your gig
and you want to seem like you're on the
up-and-up and you want to seem like
you're you know evolved and in the on
the right side but you don't actually
care about funny but the problem is that
they're involved at all those kind of
people we need a we need to be brought
you don't need TV well not anymore but
you don't need anymore really they're
irrelevant they've made themselves more
relevant with this kind of thing of core
but they tell you what they do and then
they don't suck your dick until you're
making money then they come a night that
you know I go hey will you uh will you
represent me they go blow me douche and
then I you start getting some some it's
like rere to TV show
every Haidari some people still do and
mostly Nazis but he he had a show and
then he got popular online so they go
okay we'll give it to you I'll give you
this we'll give you the show now and
then now it's a storytelling show that's
still on with the Roy Wood yeah by the
way who I loved but yeah I do too so
it's just like you don't know anything
stop telling me what's funny Oh
any other you and I know it's funny
that's you know if they are going to
work for a company that is going to pay
money that's going to get involved in a
comedy business yeah there's gonna be a
bunch of people not comedy people that
are involved in the creation of comedy
and then their ego gets involved and
they want to change the suit and to this
do this to the background this and then
the show is ruined
yeah
[Applause]